whenever someone starts giving you
feedback immediately thank them as
they're say like dude thank you so much
for telling me this cuz what it'll do is
it'll encourage them to tell you even
more later what happens is people are
even afraid to give feedback cuz they've
been punished so many times for giving
it that people don't even want to give
it so if you show that you're a good
source be like oh of course I suck I'm
brand new to this it would make sense
that I suck it probably was terrible
thank you so much for telling me I want
to do better everybody will help
somebody who just admits fault and says
I want to do better you give me the
opportunity to do better most people say
yes